[Music]
we're
here on the outskirts of enac in rural
damascus
and we've just launched a vaccination
campaign for ppr testifiminal
it's a viral disease of sheep and goats
it's quite serious
[Music]
it's part of a global campaign to
eradicate this disease
but each it requires an international
effort but also a national effort in
even down to local village
level to to vaccinate large numbers of
animals
in a short period of time to make sure
that the disease isn't present and isn't
spreading
so this campaign is funded in syria
by three projects with their fail so
three three donors the russian projects
are
diffid project and orchard donors
actually very different perspectives but
they all agree on one thing that
this disease is a priority and should be
uh should be tackled
um the scale of the campaign is going to
be around about eight million doses
to be given out in the next two to three
weeks it's a very concentrated campaign
the vaccine itself is very temp
temperature sensitive
so we have to be very careful about the
cold chain and we visited the cold store
where the where the vaccine is being
held it's uh it's come from jordan
and it's kept at between two two to
eight degrees centigrade the campaign's
going to reach 180 000 herders
uh small scale livestock keepers it
enables them to protect their assets and
ultimately will help them achieve zero
hunger